we understand that it is one
nine-year-old girl who was killed and
two women there are a number of injuries
at least 14. many of whom have required
hospital treatment it clearly landed in
a residential area you can see some of
the damage behind with actual homes
being hit by debris we understand
according to the mayor of Kiev Vitali
klitschklo he says this was the debris
of a missile strike which was
intercepted by the Ukrainian air defense
system you can see it's it appears very
much a residential areas apart from the
homes you've got playgrounds where some
of the debris has fallen and right over
in this corner you've got a children's
clinic we've been hearing over the past
few days that and weeks indeed that
there's been a number several hundred
Hospital
facilities fees and Children's Clinic
which which have been hit during the
course of this this long protracted war
and that is building up towards a case
which the ukrainians are hope hoping to
put forward to the international
criminal court but the last few days the
best part of a week Kiev has woken up to
sirens and attempted missile strikes
mostly being emptied 90 of them being
intercepted by their air defense systems
and it was like that this morning again
three o'clock in the morning residents
woken up terrified
being killed and injured and that has
been the ongoing situation over the past
few days as more and more
publicity is surrounding the start of
the the counter-offensive I was talking
to someone from the Atlantic Council
this morning a former U.S ambassador who
was urging the European politicians and
the Americans to speed up their supply
of heavy weaponry and as we know
president selinski has been making this
Whistle Stop European tour trying to
push all his Partners to come forward
more quickly with happy weapon Weaponry
like The Talented to do tanks we're
hearing that after his visit with prime
minister Rishi sunak the British have
doubled their pledge of Challenger 2
tanks and are trying to push their
European Partners to supply and quickly
Supply those F-16 Jets and that I think
has prompted this increased rhetoric
particularly against against Britain
with threats made by Dimitri Medvedev
the former president pushing saying that
they are basically Eternal enemies of
Russia and suggesting that they could be
British officials could be legitimate
military targets and that will enrage
most of the European politicians
particularly the British I imagine